hi i'm zev i'm in the last year of my
phd at cmu and today i'm excited to tell
you about some work i've been doing with
isaac rosoff and michael mitzenmacher
about scheduling with noisy information
so to set the scene our work fits into
the area of algorithms with predictions
specifically we're thinking about
scheduling with predictions so we're
thinking about jobs in the queue and
deciding what order to serve the jobs in
to minimize their average delay
and the type of predictions we're going
to be working with are job size
predictions that is predictions about
how long each job will take to serve
and the twist is that we're going to be
doing all of this from a stochastic
perspective
and we're choosing the stochastic
perspective because there's lots of
systems in practice that are well
modeled by stochastic assumptions and so
we think that these this sort of
stochastic modeling theory approach
is going to provide the right insights
for scheduling in those sorts of systems
so the question we're going to answer
today is how do we schedule to minimize
delay with noisy size estimates and so
let me start by talking a bit more about
what scheduling and delay even are then
i'll talk about the specific noise
models we assume and finally i'll
discuss what can we hope to achieve in
terms of minimizing delay right what's
what are the right goal posts to aim for
okay so let me start by introducing just
what our scheduling and delay so we're
scheduling in a single server queuing
system in this work so here's a server
it does some sort of useful uh work
provides some sort of useful service
here's a queue this holds jobs that are
waiting for service we're going to
assume unlimited capacity and then this
is a job that needs some sort of work
done at the server so the amount of work
the job needs done is called its size
we'll measure size and units of time the
amount of time it needs service for and
will represent that service as the job
is a test tube and it's getting filled
with water
so we can talk about the remaining size
of a job that's the amount of work left
and we can also talk about the age of
the job that's the amount of work that's
been done so far these are also measured
in units of time
so we have arrivals to the system uh
jobs arriving in online fashion so
here's one job that's small here's a
bigger job and the arrivals happen
according to some stochastic process
so there's some arrival rate lambda and
jobs arrive at this average rate at
completely random times formerly a
possible process
there's some job size distribution from
which each job size is independently
drawn and this gives the system a
certain load
which is the average arrival rate times
the average job size and you can think
of load as the fraction of time the
server has to be busy in order to keep
up with all these arrivals in order to
get all the jobs done
and in order for the system to be stable
load has to be less than one so that's
what we're going to assume
beyond assuming that load is less than
one we won't make any further
assumptions uh that let me say the job
size distribution
this is important because in practice
different types of applications have
very different looking job size
distributions
okay so
that's the sort of stochastic queuing
model we're talk we're working with so
let's continue the story of maybe this
job at the server eventually its age
reaches its size this job is now
complete and so it exits the system
the total amount of time the job spent
in the system between its arrival and
departure is called the jobs response
time
and so this is what i mean when i say
delay for the rest of this talk delay is
a synonym for response time of jobs
okay so this job has exited the system
and we now have to decide what job gets
to go into the service next this is the
domain of the scheduling policy which
decides at every moment in time which
job to serve and it's a preemptive
process so we can decide to switch out
one job for another and we don't lose
any progress or
incur any overhead to do this preemption
okay so we've gone over single server
scheduling
and what delay means so what do we need
mean when we're saying we're trying to
optimize delay
so remember that delay means response
time but we're not just going to look at
one jobs response time because we have
this whole stream of arriving jobs we're
going to have a response time
distribution where if i look at a really
long arrival sequence and i ask you know
how long was just this job in the system
that job and so on and so forth i get
some distribution which i'll denote by
capital t
and this distribution is affected by the
arrival process and the scheduling
policy
and so my goal
in this work is going to be to design a
scheduling policy that minimizes mean
response time the average delay over all
jobs in this long arrival sequence
and so as a warm-up let's consider a
sort of easy version of the problem
let's suppose the job sizes are known so
when a job walks into the system it says
here is my size and it's exactly right
how would we schedule to minimize mean
response time then so it turns out that
the key idea is that it's better to
serve a small job in front of a big job
than vice versa
so the policy that takes this to its
natural conclusion is called srpt stands
for shortest remaining process in time
and that name basically describes what
the scheduling policy does it always
serves the job of least remaining size
and so it's not too hard to show that
srpt is optimal
in terms of minimizing mean response
time when you have access to exact job
size information
but in this talk
we don't have access to exact job size
information we only have access to noisy
size estimates
so when a job walks into our system if
we're the scheduler we see an estimated
size z and we know the true size is
somewhere around z but we don't know
exactly where
so what precise assumptions are we going
to make about the noise model we're
going to assume something that we call
beta alpha bounded noise so this is
saying that if a job has true size s
then its estimated size will be within a
factor of beta or al beta below or alpha
above
at the true size s so the mnemonic is
beta is for below alpha is for above
another perspective on this is that if
we look at a job in our system and it
has estimated size z that means its true
size is somewhere between z over alpha
and z over beta
okay so this is the assumption uh we're
gonna make on the noise um and we're
also gonna make an assumption about how
these true and estimated sizes are
generated right so we we said already
that true sizes are generated by drawing
from a distribution we're actually going
to assume that pairs
of true and estimated sizes are drawn
from some joint distribution
but we're not going to make any
particular assumption about what this
joint distribution is beyond the fact
that it's beta alpha bounded
and so
we're going to try and design a
scheduling policy that works for any
joint distribution and for any value of
alpha or beta so uh we're basically uh
going to try and design a noise
oblivious policy that works well no
matter how much noise there is and you
can also think of this as a kind of
semi-adversarial version of the problem
and that we're letting we could let an
adversary choose the particular joint
distribution and we want our policy to
perform well no matter what the
adversary chooses
okay so this is the noise model we're
working with and i want to mention that
a variation of this model has been
studied before in a worst-case setting
specifically this this beta
alpha-bounded noise assumption uh has
been studied in a line of work recently
by azar leonardi and tuitu
um at stock and soda
uh
publications recently so
um so i think it's exciting that we're
uh developing uh sort of concurrent
lines of work in both the worst case and
stochastic settings
okay so this is the noise model we're
going to be working with beta alpha
bounded noises
that come from some joint distribution
but we're not going to make any
assumptions about what that distribution
is and we're going to try and schedule
without actually knowing the
distribution
so in this setting
what's a reasonable goal in terms of
mean response time and so if we look at
the algorithms with predictions
literature there are a few kind of
common goals uh that we see when people
design algorithms for predictions
so for example consistency is one common
goal which is about having good
performance when the predictions are
very good
so formally we're going to call a policy
c consistent for some constant c
uh if that policy ps approximation ratio
namely its mean response time ratio
relative to srpt
converges to c or less as alpha and beta
converge to 1.
so that's consistency it's all about
good performance under low noise what if
there's tons of noise what if the
predictions are almost useless so a goal
that we'd aim for in that setting is
robustness so formally we'll define our
robustness as saying p is r robust if
it's approximation ratio is always
at most r for all alpha and beta
unfortunately it turns out our
robustness at least for constant r isn't
achievable in our setting
and so
and so uh so we can't hope for
robustness okay so so far we've talked
about the case of low noise and of like
really high noise what if we have medium
noise uh you know what's a goal we might
aim for it uh there especially given
that we can't get robustness so
um
so this is something that people often
try to do in the algorithms with
predictions literature but it doesn't
have a sort of common name so
we call this a concept graceful
degradation or in this talk just
graceful for short so we call a policy g
graceful
if its approximation ratio is bounded by
g times some measure of the prediction
quality
and in our setting the natural measure
of quality turns out to be this ratio
alpha over beta it's kind of the
multiplicative size window or uh in
which the size estimate lives
okay um and
and so i would call this concept of g
gracefulness it's not a new thing it's a
slightly newish that we're sort of
calling it out because i think um it
definitely doesn't have the same sort of
recognition that consistency and
robustness have
some work that studies what we would
call gracefulness uh we'll end up
calling it robustness so i think it's
important to kind of distinguish between
gracefulness as being a different thing
from robustness
and so that's something we're trying to
do in our work
okay so
we can uh where you can hope to achieve
consistency and gracefulness
and that's exactly what we're able to do
so our main contribution
is introducing a scheduling policy
that's the first that is a that has been
proven to be both consistent and
graceful in this stochastic scheduling
setting so in terms of gracefulness we
have constant g equals 3.5 and for
consistency c equals one so it's perfect
consistency and so what's new here is
both the policy itself
and these proofs uh that it's graceful
and consistent
and one thing i want to point out about
consistency in particular is that this
consistency result with c equals one is
impossible to achieve in the worst case
and so this is one difference between
the stochastic setting and the worst
case setting
all right so
let's uh recap this contribution we
introduced the first scheduling policy
that is both consistent and graceful
and so in the rest of this talk i'm
going to dissect this contribution so
the last question is like what is this
new policy and how do we bound its
performance but before we get there i
want to say a few words about what
policy even means
and
so there's a vast design space of
possible scheduling policies
and one thing we did to help ourselves
out was to narrow our focus to subclass
of scheduling policies still a very
broad class of scheduling policies but
something that was a bit easier to think
about
and and for which some queuing theory
existed to kind of help us evaluate
scheduling policies and i'll get to a
bit of that later so the design space we
ended up looking at was something called
uh scheduling policies that can be
described as rank functions
so
remember that a job's age is the amount
of time it's been in service so far
it turns out that lots of policies in
the scheduling literature can be
described as a job having some priority
which we'll call a rank
that varies as a function of age
so you know so we're going to say that
rank is some numerical priority lower
number means better priority the
server's always going to serve whichever
job has the lowest rank
and this rank can vary as a function of
a job's age and also perhaps of its
static characteristics in our case
that's going to mean size and estimated
size as an example srpt
fits into this framework it has the rank
function s minus a that is a job's rank
is its remaining size and so srpt always
serves the job of least remaining size
now of course we're going to try and
design a rank function that doesn't use
s right because we don't have access to
the true sizes so if we don't have s but
we do have z what might we do instead of
srpt well the obvious idea is well z is
going to be close enough to s so let's
just use z instead so this is a policy
that we call naive it's the naive
translation of srpt
into the size estimate setting
okay and s and naive of course also has
a rank function it's just z minus a
and so in this work we're going to be
focusing on the design space
of policies that can be described as
rank functions and so when we're trying
to design a policy we're really asking
the question what's the right rank
function
so let's start by looking at naive again
is naive the right rank function is it
going to be consistent and robust
and we might hope that naive performs
well because
z is close enough to s that z minus a is
close enough to s minus a and the
scheduling policy should do basically
the same thing
but unfortunately it turns out naive is
not even consistent
and the big problem with naive is that
its rank can go negative
so
what happens when a job has negative
rank well every job arriving into the
system
has positive rank and this job that just
went negative has the lowest rank in the
system because it's the one in service
and so no other job is going to catch it
it's going to be non-preemptable for the
rest of its time in the system
and because we have multiplicative
estimation error a really big job
that gets underestimated by even a small
factor could spend a really long time
with negative rank of being
non-preemptable and that can be really
bad news
for our mean response time
and so naive is not even
consistent all right so what can we do
instead how can we fix this problem of
naive well
i said the rank function going negative
was a problem what if we just didn't do
that right so this leads to a policy
called check mark
and check mark is consistent
but unfortunately check mark is not
graceful
at least not when beta is less than one
half
so what goes wrong when beta is less
than one half
well what does first let's remember what
beta less than one half means that means
that a job's estimated size
can be less than one half of its true
size so in the picture that would look
like a jobs true size being all the way
out here
and so let's think about what will
happen for this job uh with this true
size s and this much smaller estimated
size z
over the course of its uh service under
check mark so
by the time a job's reaching the end of
its uh time in service
its rank will have exceeded its initial
rank
and this is bad news because whenever
you reach a new worst rank of your time
so far in the system
that's an invitation for other jobs that
have been waiting with rank that was
higher than you
you might have just reached their rank
and so those jobs can now preempt you
and so whenever you reach a new worst
rank preemption becomes likely and so
checkmark has this tendency of
preempting jobs just as they're about to
finish
and so checkmark is not graceful
okay i'm out of room in my gray box of
policies that won't work so we have to
come up with the right one this time how
are we going to fix the problem with
check mark well i told you that the
problem with check mark was all about
exceeding this initial rank so what if
we just didn't do that so this leads to
a policy called radical
radical doesn't go negative
and doesn't exceed uh initial the
initial rank of a job
and we call the policy radical both
because it vaguely looks like a square
root sign
and because it has radically good
performance properties it is the one
consistent 3.5 graceful policy we've
been looking for
and so in the rest of this talk i'm
going to explain how we compare radicals
performance to srpt's performance which
is at the core of how we prove
our consistency and gracefulness results
unfortunately it turns out to be pretty
hard to directly compare radical to srpt
it's because even though their rank
functions kind of happen to coincide
when there's low noise um if there's
sorry when there's no noise if there's
even a little bit of noise then the fact
that radical starts at z and um
starts at z and then goes down to z uh
turns out to be different enough from
starting at s and going down to s
um that it's hard to do this direct
comparison
and so what we did is we
did this comparison by way of a third
policy called scale which is sort of
part way between radicals rank function
and srpt's rank function so like radical
a job's initial rank is z but like srpt
a jobs rank scales linearly down and
ends at zero by the time age equals size
s
um and so
what this means is that we can't
actually implement scale without knowing
a job's true size so you wouldn't really
use the scale policy in practice but
it's helpful for analysis because we can
compare radical to scale and then
compare scale to srpt
okay so how are we going to do these
comparisons so
uh this is where the second sentence of
this talk comes in which was that i'm in
the last year of my phd so the thesis
i'm writing is all about how do we
analyze scheduling policies in
stochastic queuing systems
and my thesis is all about two new tools
that i've developed
along with my collaborators including
isaac grossof and these new tools help
us analyze policies like radical scale
and srbt and in fact i'm really excited
about this paper in particular because
for the first time we had to use both
tools
so i'm going to tell you a little bit
about each of them so the first tool is
soap which we use to compare radical to
scale
and the second tool is called wine which
we use to compare scale to srbt so i'm
going to say just a few words about soak
and then i'll go a bit more depth into
wine and the reason i'm going to focus a
bit more on wine today is because wine
is actually potentially useful even for
worst case scheduling questions and so i
think that's a really important one to
share with the itcs community
okay so let's start with how we compare
radical to scale using this tool soap
so soap stands for schedule ordered by
hbase priority and what soap does is it
takes
basically any stochastic arrival process
and any rank function
and yields the response time
distribution it's a sort of complicated
formula the
formula for mean response time is a
little bit simpler but still pretty
complicated um
and so i'm going to leave defer the
details to the paper but the basic
version is that
because the radical and scale rank
functions are close enough to each other
and in particular because they both have
initial rank z
and never exceed that initial xe
the policies are close enough that soap
yields similar enough mean response
times for them
so that's how we do that first
comparison let's now talk about
comparing scale to srbt
using wine so wine stands for work
integral number equality and so unlike
soap which directly gave us response
time wine
is a way to get the number of jobs in
the system but this is fine because
there's a famous result in queuing
theory called little's law which says
that the mean response time is directly
proportional to the mean number of jobs
for any fixed arrival rate
and so
what and so the way wine gets us the
number of jobs in the system
is via this other quantity called our
work which i'll define soon and so what
mine does is it reduces the problem of
analyzing mean response time to the
problem of analyzing artwork or in our
case comparing scales artwork to srpt's
artwork so
in the rest of my talk i'm going to
answer some questions about wine first
what is our work second how does wine
give us n the number of jobs from our
work and then finally how do we use this
to bound scales mean response time
so let's start by defining our work and
before i define artwork let me just
define work without the r so when
queuing theorists talk about work they
just mean the
the total remaining size of all jobs in
the system
our work is going to be a filtered out
version of this total work so let's let
r be some
threshold
our work is the total remaining size of
all jobs
where i'm only counting the jobs that
are r and smaller in terms of their
remaining size so i like to visualize
our work as follows i've got some
threshold r glasses let me align the
jobs by remaining size and so when i put
on these glasses they're going to hide
the jobs that have remaining size above
threshold are
if i look at all the jobs that i can see
through the glasses and i add up their
remaining sizes
that's our work
and so the importance of our work is
that wine tells us how to get the number
of jobs from an r-work integral because
remember y stands for work integral
number equality
so wine says that under any scheduling
policy we get number of jobs from this
artwork integral
and so what we did is we basically
bounded scales our work in terms of
srpt's artwork here's what we showed we
showed specifically that scales artwork
was less than or equal to srpts mean
alpha over beta r work
the intuition here is that scale is
always serving a job not necessarily of
least remaining size but within an alpha
over beta factor of least remaining size
and so the fact that scale is only
making errors
by a factor of alpha over beta
means that its r work can be compared to
s rpt's alpha over beta artwork so we
use that same slack factor of alpha over
beta
um and so that's kind of that's kind of
the vague intuition for why this level
is true um and so once you have this
lemma and you have wine and you have
little's law you put them together and
you get this theorem that says uh and
this is a pretty simple computation once
you have the lemma um and this says that
mean response time of scale is at most
alpha over beta times mean response time
of srbt
so that's how we use wine to compare
scale to srbt so
a few more comments about things on this
slide first i want to mention that wine
also holds in the worst case in fact it
holds very generally it
the theorem is really that if you look
at any system
it doesn't matter kind of how the system
got to its current state if you just
take a picture of its current state and
you count the number of jobs and then
you do the r work integral you get the
same thing
so that's the first thing i want to say
the second thing i want to mention is
that this lemma and theorem can be
generalized slightly so
remember that i mentioned earlier that
scale isn't a policy you could actually
do because you have to know a job's true
size in order to scale linearly down to
it
but if you were in a system where you
had uh not just an initial size estimate
but a
dynamically updating remaining size
estimate
then you probably couldn't do exactly
scale but you might have a sort of noisy
version of scale that you could do
and this lemma will also work if you're
doing some sort of noisy version of
scale
so that's what i wanted to say about
wine in summary what wine does is it
reduces the mean response time
comparison to an artwork comparison
and we showed that the artwork amounts
were close enough between scale and srbt
that they have similar enough mean
response times
okay let's summarize what we talked
about today so we discussed the problem
of minimizing mean response time when we
only have access to noisy size estimates
and this is a difficult problem because
the natural policies we'd think of end
up performing badly for example the
naive translation of srpt into size
estimate world ends up not even being
consistent so it has poor performance
even when the noise is very low
so to solve this problem we came up with
a new policy which has provably good
performance specifically we showed it as
one consistent so perfect consistency
and 3.5 graceful
and we proved this result using a
creative cocktail of two recently
developed uh tools from cueing theory
and so i'm excited about this general
direction
of algorithms with predictions uh where
we kind of consider stochastic versions
of the problems and i'm interested in
developing tools uh theoretical tools
for analyzing these stochastic problems
that go beyond just scheduling and
queuing so if you're curious to talk
about algorithms with predictions or you
have any questions about this talk feel
free to get in touch i'd be delighted to
hear from you